hallo leute ich es wieder normal fahren
und willkommen zu diesem neuen
spirituellen video namaste namaste ich
weiß der titel ist komisch weil messer
und esoterik hat sich bis jetzt noch nie
so getroffen aber es gibt einen grund
warum ich dieses video auch zu 80
prozent ernst meine im februar bin ich
in diese wohnung hier eingezogen und ich
habe sie schon eingerichtet die wände
gestrichen alles hübsch dekoriert aber
ich fühle mich immer noch nicht so als
ob das wirklich mein zuhause wäre
und dann kommt noch dazu dass ich seit
februar panik und angststörungen habt zu
denen ich vielleicht irgendwann mal was
sagen werde heute ist es jetzt noch
nicht thema und ich fühle mich allgemein
ziemlich nervös das ist komisch wenn ich
das alles vorher gesagt und ich fühle
mich eigentlich total scheiße die
letzten wochen und wahrlich situation
nicht einfach akzeptieren kann dachte
ich mir
frage ich das internet und google hatte
mir sehr viel zu diesem thema zu sagen
der grund warum ich mich hier nicht wohl
fühle könnte sein dass zu viele negative
energien in der luft schweben legen um
wandern und diese negativen energien
könnten aus vielen verschiedenen gründen
hier gelandet sein
einerseits könnten es tote menschen
seien hier ist aber glaube ich keiner
verstorben weil die wohnung noch nicht
so alles dann könnten also tode passion
von draußen
[Musik]
ja geister halten wollen wir mal nicht
um heißen brei herum reden es könnten
einfach geister herum seien die
ungebeten hier ihren unfug treiben und
zwar so zu sagen es kann aber auch sein
dass die mieter die vorher in dieser
wohnung gewohnt haben dramatische
ereignisse hatten erlebnisse viel streit
selber sehr negativ die ganze zeit waren
uns das liegt hier noch der wirklich das
als ich glaube ja
da evtl
und natürlich auch wenn gäste ein und
ausgehen hinterlassen sie energie da und
dann hab ich noch mit meinem akupunkteur
darüber gesprochen weil ich ihnen gesagt
habe dass ich mich unwohl fühle und dass
ich in mich in der praxis zum beispiel
mega wohl fühle und er hat gesagt ja was
glaubst du denn wir euch hier regelmäßig
die energien aus und so was und dann
dachte ich mir so art ist das wirklich
ein ding und ich denke mir jetzt nur so
ne so lasse ich nicht mit mir umgehen
nicht in meinen eigenen vier wänden
ich zahle hier übertrieben viel miete
jeden monat so viel dass es wehtut ich
will mich hier wohlfühle deswegen habe
ich noch mehr geld ausgegeben für die
die energie raus bringen sollen denn ich
habe viele viele seiten gefunden in
denen das thema ganz groß besprochen
will und ich habe mir die wichtigsten
notiert dazu muss man aber auch sagen es
gibt sachen die nichts kosten uns war
die unordnung wegschaffen klingt auch
logisch denn sauberkeit macht bessere
laune so ich habe schon die letzten zwei
tage diese wohnung so was von aufgeräumt
dass ich hoffe dass es wirkt zweiter
titel den es auch für umsonst gibt
lüften wo wir auch schon bei tipp nummer
drei wäre salzkristalle lampen also seit
christa lampen sehen nicht nur total
cool und esoterisch aus die sollen
wirklich die luft auch reinigen weil sie
negative ionen in die luft und auspacken
und die negative
irgendwas in der luft dann
neutralisieren wissenschaftlerin vanessa
und durch ihr licht und wie das licht
durch den stein bricht hat es wohl ganz
viele tolle auswirkungen auf den
menschen und deswegen habe ich zwei
stück geholt und eine kommt auf jeden
fall ins schlafzimmer kam in meinem
schlafzimmer und das ist ein porno
einstieg des staates vorne und heinzmann
meinerseits kristall ampel ecke ok wo
stände sie hin also ich habe eigentlich
schon einen satz gefunden den ich habe
ich ganz cool finde hier gleich am
eingang macht die lampe meisten sind
weil wenn dann die negativen energien
reinkommen wollen dann klingt die lampe
sie auf war das leuchtet echt schön und
die sogar dem bestand des marktes
erfüllt die zweite lampe kommt in mein
arbeitszimmer ja auch hier habe ich ein
ich schlafe sehen aber die muss ja also
es wird ja auch nachgesagt dass sie
elektronische geräte das aufsaugt
gegenwärtig kulti am schreibtisch zu
haben oder strahlte die ganze ins
gesicht und des streams oder so ich habe
schon das schönste schild gebracht der
positive gedanken gemacht hat warum
braucht und nicht liebe geschrieben hat
weil du kein platz mehr das wäre ich
kein zweites er also ich brauche dafür
liebe zwei es und ich hatte keinen also
nur noch 1
[Applaus]
es geht weiter das geht jetzt schon sehr
in die app kann im magic weg richtung
mit diesem pendelt kann man jetzt
schauen was für energien so in der
wohnung sodass benutzt man zum beispiel
auch bei feng shui um zu gucken ob das
bett analysestelle steht wenn das pendel
ausschlägt das natürlich scheiße
und wir werden jetzt die wohnung pendeln
das war eine negative energie abonniert
meinen kanal gibt ein like folgt mir
finster gramm
[Musik]
wenn man zum beispiel wenn das bett
nicht an seiner richtigen stelle steht
feng shui mäßig dann hat man unruhigen
schlaf
[Musik]
die google stellte auf einmal ist schaut
kein fernseher
er macht unspektakulär
gleichzeitig so spannend habe seine
arbeit zu tun hat negativ negativ
halo ist hier irgendwer wenn jemand ist
dann bringt das pendel wette zum
ausschlagen
[Musik]
ach ja kein zu wackeln
ich habe gerade im internet gelesen dass
man dem pendel auch fragen stellen kann
und man muss ihnen vorher aufladen mit
seiner körperwärme muss man seinen
ellbogen abstützen und erstmal und man
kann die mal fragen stellen ja nein
fragen und erstmal muss man schauen was
überhaupt ja und nein jetzt möchte ich
ein jahr ein jahr lag ich also wenn es
nach links und rechts keine listen ja
okay was worauf kann ich ganz klar nein
antworten mag ich diese wohnung nein
nein mag ich nicht nein
nein wenn du nach vorne und nach hinten
und okay wir machen noch mal eine jahr
sache finde ich hundewelpen süß ja ja ja
ich bin eine welt
er pendelt wieder von links und jetzt
kann ich ihm fragen stellen die mein
unterbewusstsein weiß aber nicht ich
mache noch mal eine neue sache die klar
ist uns ist es hier nicht mehr weiß ich
schon was ich zu abend essen werde
meinen job
warum penne dürfe dort ich heiße
wirklich so ruhig also die seite meinte
dass zeit die das unterbewusstsein hat
muskel zu können und so auch ausflug
sollte ich mir heute was zu essen
bestellen ja klare antwort mein
unterbewusstsein möchte bestellt das
essen haben endlich dazu antworten auf
die tiefen fragen des lebens gibt es in
dieser wohnung energien die raus müssen
und jetzt technics liebe ich mich selber
ja
ich hab nicht wie es zu teuer pendeln
kann wenn ich jetzt nicht unterstütze
weißen zu unterstützen
ja da ist aber wirklich das
unterbewusstsein bei diesen dingern
waren ich und mein akupunkteur uns nicht
so einig es ist jetzt immer dachte wir
kommen ja ich habe kaktus eingegeben und
dann waren da so verschiedene kakteen in
diesen köpfen muss erst eine positive
energien eher damit geweckt
ich darf hier drin sind kakteen denn
kakteen sollen mit ihren spitzen nadeln
energien aufspalten
ist doch klar ich habe dann noch mal
meine bestellung geguckt die
abgebildeten pflanzen sind nicht
enthalten
tipp nummer sechs öllampen und
bienenwachs care sollen auch eine
positive auswirkung haben
hörmer sammer finde ich cool und clever
man will ja quetschen weil die so
aufgeräumt sind bienenwachskerzen sollen
gut sein weil in anderen kerzen steigt
auch sehr
wir sind eigentlich heute noch nie
bienenwachs gart frei ich kann voll
attackiert mit jeder kerze die ich jetzt
ans ende wünsche ich mir positive vibes
die papiere müssen los mit dir lieber
bienen gott im himmel geheiligt werde
dein hund zu richten wie sie kerzen zu
hause an haben
[Musik]
staffel
aber ich habe das gefühl die bewährten
so schnell abbrennen wir verteilen die
kerzen doch jetzt in jeden raum dafür
auf den raum verlassen meinem herzen hat
man das ist auch jetzt sicher oder von
paketen von nachbarn die sie nicht
abholen alles was hier noch drin ist
geht er jetzt bitte mit der kerze die
frau widmann die für quetschen
amen wenn wir können auch vorsehen wenn
die wohnung abbrennt dann ist sie auf
jeden fall aber wir sind auf dem
absoluten höhepunkt dieses tages
angekommen denn wir werden die negativen
energien ausräuchern ich habe selber
raucher geholt das erste was wir machen
müssen sind die rauchmelder abmachen das
musst du machen keine gute idee freunde
keine gute idee positive energie
positive gedanken wir werden jetzt alles
negative raus räuchern
es war die letzte aufgabe das vorher
zurück
[Musik]
[Applaus]
genau so ein riesen scheint sich nun
gerade ein haus es gibt bei dir
[Musik]
und wenn das nicht geöffnet umziehen
jetzt müssen wir lüften sie kann euch
nicht vorstellen wie warm und salbei
artig ist jetzt schon gericht oder
[Musik]
sind die negativen energien noch hier
nein das video könnte auch youtuber
dürfen so ist haben bereits kommen wir
jetzt zum grau finale
du bist das leben du wirst niemals
bereit dafür sein körper suche nach
balance tiefenreinigung diese mischung
geht in die tiefe sie hilft alte
festsitzende energie schwingungen in uns
selbst in gegenständen oder
räumlichkeiten sanft doch nachhaltig
aufzulösen die atmosphäre wird spürbar
leichter und rainer es riecht gut
bestückt gewesen wir nicht über den
placebo-effekt die nacht
ich weiß womit ich negative energien
zurzeit verbinde ich weiß nie was ich
anziehen soll ich fühle mich immer so
unwohl in meinen klamotten hier muss
irgendwas negatives sein wie ein
kleiderschrank gefällt mir ab jetzt
sofort die krämpfe zu ok cool und was
macht sie da ja leute und so reinigt man
seine wohnung von negativen energien ich
muss sagen es fühlt sich sehr schön
gerade hier an sehr ruhig und entspannt
liegt wahrscheinlich auch daran dass man
das alles in so einer zeremonie gemacht
hat alles muss man natürlich mit einem
augenzwinkern sehen und falls jetzt das
bedürfnis hat was ganz böses zu
schreiben weil ihr das alles für humbug
haltet dann erspart euch auch diese
negative energie fragt euch mal wie viel
negative energie ihr am tag dazu
verwendet oder erst beschwert weil ihr
euch über etwas aufregen volt und ja ich
habe euch das video spaß gemacht ich
berichte euch dann in den nächsten
wochen tagen darüber ob es mir jetzt
hier besser geht oder ob ich umziehen
muss ich denke aber nicht ich glaube
wirklich daran
und mit meinem aura balance prey
kann sowieso nichts passieren dann
abonniert